let's bring in a hall-of-famer LaDainian
Tomlinson on the show now today the NFL
Network analysts is currently in El Paso
Texas with Kellogg's Frosted Flakes
mission tiger and Dick's Sporting Goods
foundation to give middle school kids
access to school sports as a Sun Bowl
alum and Texas native LT is teaming up
with Tony the Tiger to give every kid in
El Paso a chance to play what's up LT
I'm doing great man you're always doing
something for somebody else you you know
that you're a giver oh I appreciate it
man I enjoy doing it and you know this
particular initiative Dan is is really
special man because as you know the
funding for middle schools are getting
cut back now a lot of these middle
schools they can't even afford to fill
13 some sports anymore they don't have
the equipment and so with this with this
mission tiger and the did Sporting Goods
Foundation this sports matter grant is
going to give away five hundred thousand
dollars man Wow and and in El Paso in
middle school there's 27,000 kids so
that's how many kids will benefit from
this grant LT did you hear the poll
question yes so which one of those guys
Russell Wilson Lamar Jackson
deshaun Watson who else I'll leave off
the list Brockman Russell will choose
yeah Oh Patrick mom so that's he had
role went for the next five years I'm
rolling with Patrick my homes and here
is why you know we've seen in only his
first year last year been the full-time
starter I mean we've seen some amazing
things from Patrick we've seen some
no-look passes we seem to roll out to
the left and throw the ball all the way
across your body you know for a big
completion to keep the game you know in
enhance for them and ultimately win that
game against Baltimore parents are
coming homes can also escape the pocket
he could scramble around you know he
could use his legs and
I think he's only gonna get better you
know remember this is only his second
year being the full-time starter and so
I think over these next five years we're
talking man we might see things that
we'll never seen from the quarterback
position because of Patrick Mahone so if
I had one of these guys I'm taking I'm
taking Patrick my arms Patrick mahomes
gonna get better after 50 touchdown
passes last year it's hard to get better
LT man but what if he what if he throw
you know close to 50 more I mean he
doesn't have to get to 50 but what is
consistently he's 4045 48 I mean think
about that no one has done that
consistently so I think he has that type
of talent if he wouldn't have got hurt
this year remember Dan at the beginning
of the year we were talking about him
Dornan for another 50 touchdowns you're
right we were talking about that so I
think this guy you know he's immensely
talented and I think is not out of the
question that he says the single-season
touchdown record one year oh I wouldn't
doubt it 21 touchdown passes for Patrick
mahomes this year to just three
interceptions I gotta ask you about
running backs Lt each of the last two
seasons there have been nine 1000 yard
rushers at the end of the year and this
year there's already nine now I'm
including Lamar Jackson in there and you
have Nick Chubb Derrick Henry Christian
McCaffrey all over 1200 yards our
co-worker at NFL Network Maurice
jones-drew said he feels like Derrick
Henry is going to reset the running back
market in terms of contracts which is he
Kelly at making 15 million years at the
top of that list you agree with that
there can we yeah no no no no because
you know Derrick has to get taken off
the field at times you know meaning you
know he his value goes down as a past
catcher out of the backfield I think
Christian McCaffrey has it
to reset the running back market I
certainly believe say corn Berkeley
would do it whenever his time is up and
I would even go as far as to say don't
sleep on Alba camara you know I know
he's been hurt a little bit this year
but he's the ultimate weapon for the
Saints I believe they don't want to keep
him there and so he's gonna demand a big
contract but no I don't think their
camera will set the running back market
reset the running back market I should
say it'd be kind of a quiet year for
camara as a Tennessee guy I had huge
expectations and I know all the fantasy
football owners out there drafted him
a lot of them in the in the top five
thought he was gonna put up bigger
numbers this year if there's one guy out
there right now who is LT who is the
most like LT I know there can never be
I mean you broke the mold LT but the
most like you is it McCaffrey I think I
think it's a mix between McCaffrey and
say Cohn and the reason why I say is a
corn is because of his lateral movement
being able to jump from one hole to the
next you know his lateral quickness he
can get up on a defender and jump
laterally and just make that guy miss
and so that's what I see I see myself in
his game and that aspect now the overall
being a versatile running back I see
myself in Christian absolutely being
able to do a little bit of everything
you know and then the amount of plays
don't that Christian plays then it's
incredible I mean a man plays over 90
percent 97 percent of the plane he
doesn't come off the field that's
incredible yeah it's amazing I feel like
Le'Veon Bell used to be like that before
he got focused more on on bowling than
he was football obviously you're
familiar with that story LT what would
you say to Le'Veon Bell who wasn't
playing on Sunday because he was sick
had family in town and decided to go out
Saturday night and go bowling what would
you say to Le'Veon in the running back
room on Monday
simply tell my disappointment I am and
in his decisions because like there is
no way there lay beyond didn't think
that was going to be bad optics you know
there's no way that he could have said
okay I've been ruled out for the flu but
it's okay for me to go play ball to go
bowling the night before the game when
I'm supposed to have the flu and B not
being able to play because of the flu
until you know it sends a bad message to
everyone in our organization you know of
what kind of stuff are they letting the
players get away with who runs the team
you know is it the head coach or is it
the players do they do what they want to
do or can the coach step in you know to
correct some of these actions and then
for them to say you know this was his uh
you know it would be handle his
discipline will be handled internally
what does that mean like what are you
guys I mean it's amazing to me so and
lay beyond know that he knows that
wasn't the right thing to do um and so
of course I would have had you know
something to say about it I'm sure his
money back hoes have to say something
talk about well you would think you
would know far better than I but you you
are asked about that to say it wasn't a
big deal
you guys are just making it a big deal
why not just own it and say you know
what that was pretty stupid I had a
bunch of family in town I was feeling
okay I knew I wasn't playing because
they didn't want me around the team it
was precautionary this was a better way
to handle it right I agree just own it
absolutely to say it's not a big deal it
is a big deal you know because it sends
a bad message and it has all of us
talking about it so it is a big deal
right why he could have definitely found
a bit better what's going on with your
Chargers man I mean I know injuries have
been a big issue you've been very
involved with the organization are you
still going to every every home game yes
I am yeah you know you know we sit up
and talk about this this whole injury
thing every year but I really believe
being it's when the injuries
happen and who they happened to so think
about this Philip Rivers you know his
greatest asset is being able to stand in
the pocket and deliver the football
accurately and if you get pressure on
him he cannot do that well he started
the season not having his best offensive
lineman and we're also calling for his
medical issue yes miss most of the year
you had guys in and out of the Lana
Melvin Gordon wasn't there because the
contract situation under Henry got hurt
you know he was gone part of the season
and so now you have a group of guys that
that haven't played together and so
there's no chemistry on the offensive
side of ball you're starting to see it
now because they're all playing together
again but you can say the same thing
about the defense so we talk about this
every year but it's the fact that the
injuries happened to the wrong players
and a long time right who's more likely
to be in LA next season when they open
up that new stadium Phillip Rivers from
Melvin Gordon Phillip Rivers yeah I
think you know if if a contract
situation with Melvin Gordon couldn't be
worked out before the season the first
month of the season like why would I
have hope in thinking it's going to be
worked out at the end of the season when
he's totally a free agent when he's
gonna have other suitors probably
offered him more money right you know so
I just don't see him coming back
whereas Phillip I see you know a young
quarterback coming in you still needing
Phillips experience possibly hoping that
Phillip can still give you something not
having to rush a young quarterback into
play there is so much to benefit in
having Phillip Rivers combat chief
Phillip Rivers around for another year
to draft a quarterback have him ready to
go and Phillip can walk off into the
sunset after a great career I have to
ask you LT I know was a few weeks ago
but I was shocked as many were that you
were not on the NFL 100 all
time running back team how many times a
day do you get asked about that right
now um well it's starting to uh a little
bit yeah it's starting to dissipate in a
little bit but but I will say you know
at the beginning you know when it first
happened I had so many people calling me
talking about it and quite frankly you
know I was disappointed as well as well
who doesn't want to be on the all-time
team I think more than anything there I
was I was disappointing more to the fact
that there isn't a 21st century running
back on that list not even Marshall
Faulk you know so in my opinion I'm
thinking man what does that say about
our generation of football do is there
no respect for the 21st century football
even left JJ Watt off the list right so
I mean I don't get you know how to vote
took place but certainly not to have
Marshall Faulk who is our generation
versatile backs who we all want it to be
like it is pretty appalling so you're
gonna have a bone to pick with Bill
Belichick when you see him next at this
point what do you want to say to Bill
Belichick that's a good point
maybe stop videotaping the sidelines I
mean that's just me I know he had
nothing to do with always a pleasure my
friend I hope to catch up with you at
the Super Bowl keep up the good work
how's the little one doing in football
good man he's uh he's now no more
football Dan is strictly baseball and
soccer and he's doing terrific man
that's great the all-star last year
baseball he's doing great thanks for
coming from good stock LT one of my
favorites one of my favorite co-workers
one of my favorite players to watch
thanks for the time buddy all right man
that was in vain Ian talents in Hall of
Fame running back one of the best of all
time for more of the Rich Eisen show
tune - audience Channel 239 on DirecTV
for free on BR Live or download the Rich
Eisen show app